I think the best answer is really to search the web.
Buying a book, well that takes a lot of time, that cost money.
It might eventually help us but we're not patient enough, at least most computer sciences
aren't patient enough to wait for a book to arrive.
Phoning a friend might be a good thing to do and probably a good idea to call your mother,
but that's not probably not what's going to help you to make union and if you phone your friends
through our programmers and keep asking them how to solve all your programming problems,
they might not be your friends for much longer.
Reading a Python documentation could definitely help, but you'll have to know where to start
and you'll have to read a lot before you got to something helpful.
Search engines are your friend.